Sal: Hi, this is Sal
Khan of the Khan Academy.
I just wanted to thank everyone out there
for another great year.
We're now reaching over 10
million students per month
and then many of you all have noticed
amazing partnerships and the content
that we've been able to work
together to put out there.
One thing I do like remind
people at this time of year
is that we are a 501(c)(3)
not-for-profit organization.
The only reason why we can exist,
why we can continue to
put out this content,
is with the help of
supporters like yourself.
I'll just throw that out there.
If you're in the position,
whether it's $5, $10,
or a lot more than that,
every penny is very much appreciated by us
at Khan Academy so that
we can continue to try
to deliver a free world-class
education to the world.